zacarilla camina sobre la que iba a ser
su casa una estructura de dos viviendas
para su familia recién destruida por
excavadoras israelíes
queríamos construir nuestra vida aquí
dar un paso más pero la municipalidad no
lo aprobó y pedimos permisos de
construcción pero nos rechazaron de
todas las formas posibles
las autoridades israelíes justifican las
demoliciones por falta de permisos pero
casi nunca se les otorgan a palestinos
de Jerusalén este que se ven forzados a
edificar sin papeles
además si reciben una orden de
demolición y no destruyen sus
estructuras el gobierno les cobra el
trabajo zacarilla y su tío empezaron a
demoler y aún así la municipalidad les
envió dos maquinarias generándoles una
deuda de 30 mil dólares
con mis propias manos enviamos fotos a
la municipalidad y no dijeron nada de
que vendría de nuevo porque no les gustó
aunque las demoliciones son prácticas
regular han aumentado bajo el nuevo
gobierno israelí de extrema derecha en
solo tres meses se han producido la
mitad de los derribos de 2022 según
indica la oficina de la ONU para asuntos
humanitarios
las demoliciones resultan en familias
perdiendo su lugar de residencia el
acceso a sus medios de vida y a
servicios básicos casi 150 palestinos de
Jerusalén este han sido desplazados más
de la mitad son niños
con ese miedo malviven los habitantes de
yavel mukaber donde las autoridades
amenazan con destruir 132 viviendas es
el caso inminente de feras y su familia
que por cinco años construyeron un hogar
en tierras de su abuelo
en toda esta área Residencial Que está
debajo de esta calle han recibido avisos
de demolición
la posibilidad de ver caer tu casa la
casa de tus sueños de tu familia en la
que viviste durante años es un
sentimiento muy doloroso para no ver sus
posesiones entre las ruinas la familia
desalojado la casa como muchos denuncian
que esta política busca echarlos de la
ciudad no permitir las construcciones en
un acto para reducir la presencia árabe
en Jerusalén quieren impulsar la
expansión de la existencia judía e
israelí para alcanzar los objetivos de
los extremistas judíos
sin otro lugar al que ir feras piensa
resistir tanto él como sus vecinos
esperan Evitar que las luces de esta
colina sean apagadas